trasladó usted un poco el panorama de
gobernabilidad que dejarían los
distintos escenarios después de estos
comicios no en estos momentos digamos
que el oficialismo tiene sensibilidades
que forman una mayoría no podríamos
decir en el parlamento Pero cómo podría
cambiar esto después de estas elecciones
bueno podría cambiar en la medida en que
pueda ganar Bernardo Arévalo creo que es
digamos el punto de o el escenario
distinto Porque si al final de cuentas
Hablamos de una posible victoria de
Sandra Torres pues sabemos y conocemos
un poco que ha hecho pactos con el
gobierno de yamaté Y eso no cambiaría
Entonces en ese sentido Yo creo que el
único escenario posible donde hay una un
cambio significativo sería en el caso de
Bernardo Arévalo como presidente Pero
sería muy interesante ver cómo se
elaboran en términos de Que obviamente
los partidos que Obviamente le le
secundan un poco en la votación pues son
partidos que no son muy digamos
allegados a sus posiciones de
transformación entonces ahí se un poco
digamos una especie de choque entre un
presidente que trataría cambiarle el
estado de cosas en Guatemala Y de alguna
forma una serie de partidos Que
obviamente no quieren buscar digamos ese
cambio sino que quieren mantener ese
estatus Manuel Camilo muy brevemente Y
de forma concreta Cuál es serían los
campos que deberían a tocarse en esta
próxima legislatura para cambiar
radicalmente el curso del panorama en
Guatemala y no continuar con el
continuismo valgase la redundancia tiene
que tocarse alguna forma lo del estado
es digamos digamos un punto necesario
para recuperar la confianza la
institucionalidad también un poco hablar
de los partidos políticos porque los
partidos políticos están de alguna forma
naciendo y muriendo al mismo tiempo y
eso no genera una estabilidad a lo largo
de digamos del tiempo y también temas
relacionados con la economía es decir
Cómo afrontar un poco el tema de la
diversificación de la economía hablar un
poco también de la desigualdad
porque al final de cuentas tenemos un
país que está creciendo pero que no
reestruye Su riqueza lo más adecuado
posiblemente